it's 1991 and the Soviet Union is
fracturing
and down here another Communist party is
failing Yugoslavia a Federation of six
countries is ripping itself apart their
economy is in ruin and they are
replacing communism with nationalism the
kind that thrives on focusing on ethnic
and religious differences by the end of
1991 Croatia Slovenia and Macedonia have
all declared independence Macedonia is
allowed to leave peacefully but Slovenia
and Croatia fight Wars to be independent
from Yugoslavia and then you have Serbia
populated primarily by Christian serbs
and they were not going to let
Yugoslavia fully fall apart together
with Montenegro they attempt to become
the successor state to Yugoslavia after
all it was they who held the most power
in Yugoslavia and who comprise the
majority of the Yugoslav army they
didn't want independent states they
wanted to hold on to their majority to
their power another country Tree in this
crumbling Federation was the Socialist
Republic of Bosnia and Herzegovina
almost half of this country were Bosnian
Muslims called bosniaks and about a
third were Christian serbs similar to
the Christian serbs Living up here but
living in Bosnia the other 17 percent
were croats for a long time these groups
had lived side by side in relative peace
they had a common ideology communism the
idea of Yugoslavia but as all these new
countries were being created no one
wanted to end up in a new nation
controlled by the other side so it's
late 1991 and a largely croat region
declares itself an independent state
from Bosnia it wasn't recognized
internationally while some croat leaders
want to secede from the country entirely
they first agree to cooperate with the
government of Bosnia and Herzegovina
acting like a state within a state the
next year Bosnia holds an independence
vote 63 percent of the population turns
out and the results are that 99 of the
voters say yes they want to be
independent from Yugoslavia these
numbers imply that it was mostly
bosniaks that voted with the Bosnian
serbs boycotting the vote as most were
against becoming a minority in a new
Bosnia
so after the independence vote passed
the Bosnian serbs declared their own
state within the borders of Bosnia it
was called Republica serbska no one
recognized this new self-declared
country besides one and it was the one
that mattered Serbia and Montenegro now
had this leader an important part of the
story his name was Slobodan milosevic he
recognizes the new Serb state within
Bosnia and this marks the start of the
Bosnian War
[Music]
[Applause]
hey before I dive into this I just need
to tell you that we don't have a sponsor
for today because it's sort of hard to
find sponsors for videos like this
luckily the subscribers over at nebula
help make these videos possible we
publish our videos there every week a
week early so our next week's video
about Antarctica one of my favorite
videos we've ever made ever it's
freaking beautiful is up now on nebula
you can go watch it it's 2.50 a month
and it helps support us making videos
like this I'll give more detail on that
at the end of the video for now let's
dive into this now before we go on we
have to look back up here at Serbia this
leader milosevic this guy was a hyper
nationalist he made his career stirring
up ethnic tensions between serbs croats
and bosniaks so he's seen all of this as
a good thing as an opportunity to
further his vision of creating a new
greater Serbian Nation across the former
Yugoslavia and remember Serbia is where
the capital of the former Yugoslavia was
the Yugoslav Army is dominated by serbs
so milosevic is able to direct to this
professional Army to launch an offensive
to help the serbians in Bosnia secure
their new claimed territory
foreign
to fight back the bosniaks and croats
form an alliance to protect their own
chances of Independence but serbs have
this large professional Army on their
side it's much more powerful and it
quickly surrounds the Bosnian Capital
City positioning tanks artillery and
snipers on the hills around the city
blocking roads and supply routes their
goal is to take the capital as fast as
possible and to end this war quickly
they start firing indiscriminately
attacking civilian populations with
tanks artillery and sniper fire killing
thousands in a siege that would last for
years and while this city was majority
bosniak croats and serbs lived there too
but the serbs pummeled It Anyway the U.N
quickly attempts to negotiate with
milosevic and Serb forces and they reach
a quick agreement to withdraw the
Yugoslav Army but what really happens is
the Yugoslav Army just gives up control
of around a hundred thousand Serb troops
who mostly continue fighting for the
serbs in Bosnia as Yugoslav forces
withdraw from Sarajevo as part of this
agreement the retreating forces are
attacked by bosniak troops an unknown
number of Yugoslav Army Personnel are
killed bosniak commanders would later be
charged with war crimes for this attack
as the war rages on serbs escalate the
brutality all over the country routinely
identifying bosniak homes ransacking and
burning them down rounding up civilians
separating the men from the women and
sending the men to concentration camps
or executing them women are sent to
prisons where they suffer abuses and
human rights violations that I'm not
going to describe here for how atrocious
they are you can go to the sources for
details the point here is that what the
serbs are doing is starting to look like
an ethnic cleansing of the land they
claimed meanwhile the International
Community is hesitant to get too
involved Beyond cutting off the Yugoslav
economy with sanctions and the UN sends
food medicine and peacekeeping soldiers
they also cut off the flow of weapons
from the outside but the UN mostly
sticks to its peacekeeping principles
not interfering in the conflict not
stopping in the advance of the serbs or
the ongoing ethnic cleansing that has
begun but the situation in Bosnia is
getting worse the alliance between
bosniaks and croats is falling apart
they start fighting each other so now
bosniak forces are fighting the serbs on
one side and their former allies the
croats on the other a war within a war
as this new complicated stage of the
conflict starts croat forces surround
and begin an attack in the city of
mostar a city that the two had once
defended together back in 1992 against
the serbs croat forces capture large
portions of the city they blow up
bosniak mosques and murder bosniak
civilians in their wake things are
getting bad and in response to these
worsening conditions in Bosnia the UN
gets NATO forces to come to Bosnia to
enforce a no-fly zone basically
committing them to shoot down any planes
flying over the country but this does
nothing to stop the ethnic cleansing
that continues to escalate on the ground
so the next year the UN establishes safe
zones across the country to protect
civilians flee in the war particularly
bosniaks who were fleeing ethnic
cleansing by the Serb armies but the UN
is only as powerful as its member
nations are willing to let them be and
it turns out member nations are not
willing to commit enough troops to
actually fortify these safe zones Serb
forces regularly show up and attack the
civilians in these safe zones the United
States who's still trying to stay out of
this war helps negotiate peace between
the croats and the bosniaks thus ending
the war within the war they sign an
agreement in March of 1994
re-establishing the federal republic of
Bosnia and Herzegovina and most
importantly they renew their Alliance to
fight against the serbs things slowly
start to change in 1994. Bosnian serbs
decline a peace deal offered by the U.N
in response milosevic who's now feeling
the consequences of being cut off from
the global economy now Cuts ties with
the Bosnian serbs refusing to send them
more weapons and money he wants to
remain in power controlling his new
Yugoslavia in hopes that cutting ties
with the Bosnian serps who are doing all
these terrible things will convince the
West to begin trading with him again so
milosevich's support is now gone but
even still the Bosnian serbs continue
their campaign of horror committing
atrocities all over the country but it's
not just the serbs bosniaks and croats
have also devolved into committing
terrible violent human rights abuses
against civilians as the war rages on
NATO continues to enforce their no-fly
zone shooting down a serp jet and
getting more and more pulled into this
conflict as Serb forces get Bolder
former President Jimmy Carter travels to
Bosnia and negotiates a four-month
ceasefire it mostly holds with a few
exceptions but the ceasefire expires
they can't agree on a new one and the
fighting starts again Serb forces are
able to steal heavy weapons from the U.N
and then use them to kill civilians NATO
continues to ramp up air strikes Serb
forces respond by taking U.N
peacekeepers hostage and shooting down a
usf-16 the Serb forces are feeling
emboldened at this point they have
consistently held around 70 percent of
the land in Bosnia and even pushed back
U.N peacekeepers without major
consequences and they see an opportunity
for one last big offensive to end the
war and secure all of this land they
just need to take over the UN safe zones
kick the UN out and then take Sarajevo
with overwhelming Force
foreign
[Music]
izza a un safe Zone where nearly 10 000
bosniaks are seeking Refuge the UN had
taken away their weapons they were
totally unarmed but protected by U.N
forces on July 11 1995 2000 Serb
soldiers marched into the town they meet
no resistance from the U.N soldiers who
decided to maintain their neutrality and
defend supplies and food for their
refugees instead of the people
themselves but these U.N soldiers were
really just 370 Dutch soldiers they were
outmatched anyway so some Retreat others
are captured the Serb forces then Round
Up 8 000 bosniak men and boys and then
they systematically execute them
comprising the deadliest genocide on
European soil since World War II
foreign
the surviving refugees abandoned by the
International Community flee the
violence in cerebr they fled to other
areas telling the stories of this mass
murder the UN would later report that
all sides violated the Geneva
conventions but described this Serb
offensive as quote systematic ethnic
cleansing and at this point the United
States can no longer stand by and watch
this happen so in late 1995 the Clinton
Administration pursues a new strategy
they plan for the U.N to eventually pull
out of Bosnia the U.S and NATO would
keep them safe the plan also ensured
that the U.S would be allowed to send
weapons to the Bosnian government the
U.S then proposed a peace plan one that
divided Bosnia into two entities one for
serbs and one for bosniaks these regions
would have some autonomy and bosniaks
would control 51 percent of the country
both sides considered the US's plan but
the fighting continued but now with the
International Community squarely on
their side the croats conduct a
successful offensive in 1995 that takes
back significant Land from the serbs and
the bosniaks gain momentum in the war
the balance of power is Shifting which
forces the serbs back to the negotiating
table to cut their losses after many
rounds of negotiation and with the Serb
forces seeing the tide of the war turn
against them the Dayton Accords are
signed in December 1995 by the
presidents of Croatia Bosnia and Serbia
on behalf of all of us who would come to
see this peace take hold
you have seen what war has wrought
you know what peace can bring it was
this agreement that eventually gave us
these modern borders that divide the
country into two you have the Federation
of Bosnia and Herzegovina which is
composed mostly of bosniaks and Bosnian
croats and over here the Republica
serpska composed mostly of Bosnian serbs
which is somewhat independent with its
own political system and its own
Judiciary but it's still a part of
Bosnia and Herzegovina so the war is
over around a hundred thousand people
died during this violence and many more
Millions were forced to flee from their
homes the majority of which were Bosnian
Muslims a United Nations criminal
tribunal eventually tried 161 people for
various war crimes committed during this
war Slobodan milosevic went to jail for
the rest of his life because of his
crimes against humanity his war crimes
and genocide he died before the end of
his trial the war reshaped this country
solidifying the ethnic divides that had
been at the root of the conflict today
bosniak serbs and croats live in
relative peace though the country faces
new threats to that piece threats that
are facing lots of parts of the world
Rising nationalism a reverence for
former Serb war criminals and more calls
for Serb Independence the memory of the
atrocities committed during this
conflict still haunts this place both in
the physical scars on the land but most
powerfully in the bodies and minds of
its people
[Music]
this is a complicated story and there
are lots of feelings about it people
watching this probably disagree with the
way that I frame certain things but we
did our best to be fair and factual and
to give the best overview we could as I
said earlier finding sponsors for videos
like this is difficult
um and I really value those who
subscribe to nebula nebula is a place
where I put all of my videos ad free and
a week early so next week's video is up
now it's 2.50 a month when you subscribe
it directly goes to help us make more
videos like this and you don't just get
access to all of my videos a week early
you also get access to a huge repository
of amazing content all of it ad free
knowing that you are supporting these
creators nebula is the platform that I
watch it's like all of my favorite
YouTubers but then they go into nebula
and they make stuff that is only on
nebula like real life lore has this
really awesome series called modern
conflicts super deep dive into how War
Works in our day and age rendover
Productions has some Originals that you
can't see anywhere else it's only on
nebula polymatter has this series on
China that's an original and these are
really premium high quality series that
you can only see on nebula it's
incredibly affordable 250 cents a month
when you do the yearly thing slightly
more if you do the monthly thing and and
again a portion of that subscription
goes directly to us creators to allow us
to continue to do this I got to tell you
about next week's video it's about
mapping Antarctica and it truly is one
of the most ambitious videos I have ever
made in my entire career we tried all
this new mapping techniques with this
like paper globe that is then
geo-referenced with like Captain Cook's
like Journeys throughout the South like
it truly is an amazing piece of work
that we have been working on for a long
time and it's live right now you can go
watch it right now on nebula so more
than ever clicking the link in
description that goes to nebula and
signing up really helps to support this
channel I appreciate you all watching I
hope you enjoyed this map video we're
wanting to do more of these I used to do
these a lot back in the old days when I
was at Vox and I sort of moved away from
it and I want to get back to it so leave
me a note uh here in the comments if
this is a format that you like what
conflicts you think I should take on
what complex issues would benefit from
being mapped in this way so that's it
lots going on around here we're making
lots of really really interesting
stories right now that you will be
seeing in coming weeks or you'll be
seeing a week early if you subscribe to
nebula okay bye everyone
thank you
[Music]